hello good to see you hosting today's
event what do you hope kids take away
from your story today I'm just more here
to encourage these kids and to tell
stories with them because there's
nothing more beautiful than seeing all
these kids that are here today actually
earns being here they wanted to get back
to their community they want to inspire
other kids to do the same so I'm just
here to to be a part of it you know how
many kids look up to you who inspires
you to be a better person my mom yeah
she is constantly challenging me my
character she's you know my morals who I
am it's nice to have that person that
reflection that can be there to say hey
are you good it's just really you are
you being authentic to yourself and are
you being good to people
you're being a show you're here hosting
today I mean you're kind of doing it all
what's inspiring this girlboss side of
you I don't know I think it's empowering
when you're able to do things on your
own you know I started when I was so
young so in a way a lot of things were
held like they helped guide me and they
helped build stuff with me so now the
older I've gotten the more I realized
that I don't want to be a part of
something unless I'm truly passionate
unless I've created it unless I feel
like it means something so maybe it's
just getting older it feels like 2017 is
truly your year what's been the
highlight for you honestly I feel like
the show that thirteen reasons why I was
a really big moment for me just because
we have the book for seven years and we
worked so hard on it but everything you
know my
my family and friends I'm just a really
happy place it's been good
what do you have to say to people who
are wondering what Alex's fate is they
want a season two I know I don't know I
can't pay anything you'll see and it was
a wig it was me it was a wig yes there
was a wig everyone just so okay Celina